we went there and and to do our program
in Mexico City I loved so much about the
culture everything the only complaint I
had is towards the end of my stay I was
starting to overdose on mariachi bands
because I'm just wanting to ask you as
someone from Mexico who's born there and
grew up there I mean every time for you
they come up every time they would see
me they would come up and they would
play and they would play and first
you're like this is amazing and then
nine songs you're like how do i how do I
stop this it's a friend of mine Alfonso
Cuaron a fantastic director one said to
me that mariachis are like poppers
poppers are it's a drug yeah I mean you
can tell us more about it because I've
never tried it but just before every
show that's what it's what it's me going
oh yeah a friend of gunan told me that
is nice and then it gives you five
minutes of pleasure and excitement and
then five hours of headache and then you
go those trumpets
they don't stop they never stop
you